fact many of the best films from the
last decade also featured some of the
best movie villains we've ever seen from
insidious music teachers to scheming
lovers here are some of the biggest
meanest and most devious bad guys from
the last decade beware there are major
spoilers ahead black panther remains one
of the best and most important films in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
film's villain is easily one of its most
compelling elements we're given quite
the explosive introduction to Eric kill
monger Stephens played brilliantly by
Michael B Jordan at the start of the
film we watch him pull off one seriously
epic museum heist a military veteran who
bears scars on his body for each one of
his kills
kill monger is undeniably one of the MCS
most fascinating characters and his
motivations make a whole lot of sense
he's out for revenge after his father's
murder at the hands of his own brother
kill monger wants to use wakanda's
considerable resources to liberate black
people all over the world from
oppression but he commit so many
despicable and callous acts through the
film it can be hard to see him as a
sympathetic character there's no two
ways about it
Jordan's masterful performance easily
cements kill monger as one of the most
interesting villains of the last decade
know where I'm from and black folk
started revolutions they never had the
firepower not far into Jordan peels
directorial debut get out we meet Chris
Washington and Rose Armitage a seemingly
well adjusted couple played to
perfection by Daniel Kaluga and Allison
Williams at the start of the film
they're bracing themselves for a weekend
to visit roses parents house a sprawling
estate with no shortage of creepy
goings-on Chris is initially quite
nervous about meeting Rose's family but
Rose doesn't appear worried in the
slightest do they know I'm black
so they following an unnerving near miss
with a wayward ear their visit seems to
go just fine at first although perhaps
the conversations are a little bit
stilted and awkward at times of course
things eventually take a turn for the
decidedly sinister soon enough chris is
getting seriously freaked out by all the
bizarro things happening at the Armitage
house and he eventually tells Rose that
he wants to leave Rose seems to
acquiesce but just as it looks like he's
about to actually escape the estate the
story throws another curve ball our way
Rose refuses to give up the keys she's
decidedly not on Chris's side and in a
flash she's gone from the girl next door
to one of the decades most insidious
villains sometimes great movie villains
are seemingly normal people who
nevertheless want to ruin lives a
perfect example is the character of
Terrence Fletcher in whiplash
masterfully portrayed by JK Simmons look
at me
1 2 3 4 was i rushing he's a conductor
and teacher at the fictional prestigious
Shaffer conservatory a devoted
perfectionist and flat-out abusive
instructor Fletcher singles out a
student named Andrew played by miles
teller he's a young drummer in his first
year at the academy and Fletcher goes to
great ends to make his life a living
hell
as the two battled it out over Andrews
spot in the band some troubling
information comes to light about
Fletcher after Andrew testifies against
Fletcher in court the twisted teacher
intentionally sabotages his young
student during a pivotal performance
Simmons won a well-deserved Academy
Award for the role and gives one of the
defining performances of his long and
storied career
Fletcher isn't a super villain but he's
definitely a monster in fact he's one of
the scariest film characters in recent
memory there's simply no way to
sympathize with this guy no he might not
possess the raw brutish power of a
villain like Thanos but loki certainly
corners the market on style and panache
this god of mischief has made memorable
appearances in more than a few MCU films
including the Thor movies
and the Avengers installments beyond
that the character will be getting his
very own namesake show on Disney Plus
and it's expected to premiere on the
streaming service sometime in spring
2021 never mind the fact that loki is
supposed to be evil he's become one of
the most beloved characters in the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe the
fact that audiences are basically
rooting for him has everything to do
with Tom Hiddleston's rakish undeniably
charming performance in fact it seems
like fans are willing to overlook some
of the characters worst trespasses
simply because they love Hiddleston's
performance so much I guess I'll just
have to go to learn like I've always
done it in fact that's a large part of
what makes Loki such a great villain
even when he's conspiring against Thor
and the other good guys
he still somehow manages to win us over
well played Loki well played
in Quentin Tarantino's 2012 Western
Django Unchained Leonardo DiCaprio plays
the film's central villain Calvin Candie
he's a brutal plantation owner with a
serious taste for violence and he gets
his kicks by forcing slaves to fight to
the death
right in front of him to make matters
worse candy owns Brunhilde played by
Kerry Washington she's the wife of the
titular bounty hunter Jango played by
Jamie Foxx candy is quite unwilling to
let broom-hilda go in the hopes of
rescuing her Jango hatches a plan along
with his traveling companion dr. King
Schultz played by Christoph Waltz he
manages to infiltrate Candy's plantation
I do believe you were just getting ready
to make me a proposition about Hilda
I'm alright their plan of course goes
horribly awry DiCaprio's performances
candy is totally unforgettable from
start to finish and what a finish it is
Mad Max fury road captivated critics and
fans alike earning 10 Academy Award
nominations and ultimately raking in six
wins widely considered one of the best
action films ever made
fury road masterfully combines
heart-stopping action with an
enthralling narrative the
post-apocalyptic tale also features a
perfectly horrendous villain in the form
of immortan joe played by Australian
actor
Hugh keays-byrne we send off my war work
to bring back guzzoline from Castile
this creepy barely alive cult leader
heads an army that's fond of capturing
healthy people to subsequently use for
blood and breeding at once entirely
frail and incredibly intimidating
immortan joe is a tyrannical dictator
and it must be said a really impressive
driver not a good person though crafting
a villain as iconic as darth vader is
certainly a tall order and while his
shadow still looms over the entire
franchise JJ Abrams and Rian Johnson
managed to create an entirely new kind
of villain for the series audiences were
first introduced to kylo Ren in the 2015
film star wars the force awakens and
he's portrayed marvelously by Adam
driver an operative of the sinister
first order he didn't start out as a bad
guy
in fact he once trained as a Jedi under
Luke Skywalker himself but he was
ultimately tempted by the dark side it
happens aided by drivers explosive
thoughtful performance kylo Ren is a
multi-layered and complex villain he's
also a rather petulant one - he might be
the powerful leader of the first order
but he still succumbs to the occasional
temper tantrum which makes the character
feel all too human at times I'll destroy
her and you and almost it's always a
smart move to bring a celebrated actor
to play a vicious and unapologetically
campy antagonist and director Tycho YTD
did just that by casting Academy Award
winner Cate Blanchet as the villain in
Thor Ragnarok Thor faces a number of
obstacles throughout the film but his
biggest one is surely hella the goddess
of death Blanchett is clearly having a
blast playing the character vamping up a
storm even as she doles out death blows
by the bucketful kneel beg your pardon
Neal it's certainly a relief when hella
is defeated but it's also disappointing
that Blanchette likely won't be back for
future Thor instalments sometimes a
villain is hiding right there in plain
sight taunting us all the while and when
this formidable foe finally reveals
their true identity audiences are
treated to one seriously epic twist the
2017 blockbuster Wonder Woman is a
perfect example of this as it turns out
Ares the God of War is very much
responsible for much of the film's
mayhem and seeing as he's Diana's
half-brother he's been right under her
nose the entire time New Gods can kill
another God played by the always
mesmerizing David feuless Sir Patrick
Morgan is initially introduced to us as
an advocate for peace but no he's
actually Ares in disguise and peaceful
he is not in the film's climax he sheds
his human persona to go up against Diana
once and for all
ultimately Ares two radically different
personas not to mention feuless is
convincing wildly entertaining
performance mix in one of the last
decades most memorable movie villains it
should go without saying that you simply
can't have a list of great villains
without including fan OHS as you're no
doubt well aware he's the resident big
bad throughout multiple phases of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and for very
good reason Josh Brolin officially took
on the role in 2014's guardians of the
galaxy and right from the start makes
the character his own Thanos eventually
decides that he should help out the
universe by cutting its population in
half by any means necessary a belief
instilled in him after the people of his
home planet Titan go extinct thanks to
overpopulation little one it's a simple
calculus this universe is finite its
resources finite throughout several MCU
films Thanos spends his time assembling
the six Infinity stones to place them in
the legendary Infinity Gauntlet in
Avengers infinity war he finally
achieves his goal and snaps half of the
world's living beings out of existence
nevertheless he ultimately meets his
crushing defeat in Avengers endgame
without a doubt Fanus ranks among the
last decades greatest villains he's
cold-blooded single-minded and willing
to do whatever it takes to achieve his
goal namely kill half the population of
the universe gone girl starts out with a
rather familiar narrative adapted by
author Gillian Flynn from her insanely
readable novel the film tells the story
of a young woman named Amy Dunne played
by Rosamund Pike she's apparently gone
missing on the morning of her fifth
wedding anniversary unsurprisingly her
detached husband Mick played by Ben
Affleck quickly becomes the main suspect
in the apparent crime directed by David
Fincher gone girl incorporates clever
dreamlike flashbacks to let us see how
Nick and Amy's fairytale romance has
steadily turned sour
halfway through the film we make a
startling discovery Nick is actually
being framed by a me after she discovers
that he has been cheating on her she
goes full-fledged diabolical and totally
fakes her kidnapping she even plans to
take her own life just so she can pin
her death on Nick talk about holding a
grudge but then she eventually changes
her mind and decides she's going to try
holding on to her husband once and for
all this time throughout the film it
becomes all too clear that amy will stop
at nothing to achieve her infernal ends
she's even willing to murder her loyal
childhood loved se played by Neil
Patrick Harris and ultimately she wins
this insidious game she completely traps
Nick and the to start preparing to have
a child together
as far as Nick is concerned that's
almost certainly a fate worse than death
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]